[Music]
Wow
unbelievable what an incredible crowd
what great little kids I wanted to come
here because education is so important
and we want to make sure that the school
is good for you we think you guys can go
without lunch you won't lose a good
lunch and we want to shorten the school
day because we can't afford to fund the
schools
all right great all right well such fun
wonderful kids okay Bridget I'm done
let's go thank you so much wonderful
time great time no sir
remember you're supposed to read to the
kids all right what's very good this is
an incredible book as dumb this book
cover in a forest look at that guy so
handsome I call I've been boesky
boskie's an arbitrator my idea is dire
Steve Rubell and I in Schrager you guys
know they are the creative and studio 54
and the Palladium what is a kid good
they are incredible realistic guys who
owned studio 54 that's a place where you
could do anything yeah what the heck is
wrong they already I not job makes jokes
big children play with the kids what's
fun about them the first job where the
foreman okay you're the chief
electrician now this is the contractor
okay now this guy he's going to want to
take a kickback for everything you do
now bring me free yellow ones the
yellows are the illegals that we hire to
do the job that the guys in our chopper
on and that's the way to treat an
illegal tikkun olam right on these guys
are going to do the work the form is
going to get a kickback but he's gonna
have to pay the mob guys now the mob
guys they thought someone okay only me
this is like so much fun about building
it you kidding me
oh no oh no nigger but this is fine we
can claim insurance on you see now we
should just claim a bankruptcy against
the construction cost then we can sue to
lower the cost they forty million off a
building we don't even build then take
my name and just slap it on the front of
this building we don't even need to
construct it and that's how business
works now I'm thinking about creating a
mass deportation program where we're
going to take people who are illegal
immigrants separate them from their
families and ship them to other
countries what do you think of that
nah don't you're gonna take a white on
your head what do I do about that
oh you could just keep them here sir do
you want to go or you excuse me we're
ready babe sorry sir and they get at the
best friend right what they can get on
in there you don't know me
I shall we take share this or that Oh
sir don't do that sir - pull your pants
up circling oh my good maybe I take the
note every way I want to give you a
friendship bracelet that I made for you
in the Bell I give you this friendship
bracelet because sure now my new best
friend my only best friend over
everybody else including the last person
I was talking to is no longer my best
friend
[Music]
and
that might be like white ginseng right
green light
I like it yeah there we go
sir so we have to get going play we have
to get going
why don't I know but it's time to go
time to go get the ball someone else
yeah thank you
it's okay we have to talk to the
President of Argentina let's go we have
to find the other half of our Geneva
oh hey thank you so much you're the
President of the United States that